the reverse behind the back 3B weave no
it's not just a pile of syllables it's
also a trick I have been getting a lot
of requests for lately and I have a way
that you can learn how to do this trick
in only five steps so in this video
we're going to dive in and learn
how Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we're going to
dive into that reverse behind the back
3B weave and discover why you probably
already know the techniques for doing it
but you just need to put them together
in the right order but before we dive in
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyrro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
beckon thank you so much for supporting
my channel my work and my mission all
right so first up we need to do just a
little bit of housekeeping with the
terminology here because it may not be
clear what exactly you're going to learn
in this video normally when we learn a
behind the back 3 beat weave this is the
trick where we're learning right here
and the confusing part about this is
that in order to get into it I'm
starting with the PO spinning reverse on
my sides here but when I tuck them back
behind my back and start into the weave
it turns out the pattern is identical to
a forwards 3 beat weave if I'm looking
the other way likewise the trick that
we're going to learn today starts with
my poise spinning forwards on my sides
but when I put it behind my back all of
a sudden it turns out that the pattern
is exactly the same as a reverse weave
if I were facing in that direction this
is the trick that we're going to learn
in this video so if you have learned one
of these behind the back weaves and you
were keen on learning the other well
you've come to the right spot so I'm
going to break this down for you in five
specific steps you would use these exact
same steps when learning any weave
whether it's behind the back or not but
we're going to specifically look at them
in the context of that reverse behind
the back weave so let's dive
in so step one we have to get down our
behind the back planes if you've learned
the other behind the back wave then
you've already done a version of this
exercise what you want to do is go ahead
and get the POI spinning reverse on your
side and you want to kind of walk your
body around in a circle here while
keeping your PO and your hand in the
exact same spot you want to be able to
wrap your arm around all the way back
behind to the small of your back where
you should see the Poise spinning
forward on your side you want to then
come back around to unwrap as you're
doing this there will be a spot where as
you're going past uh the small of your
back here you're going to be switching
the orientation of your wrist so rather
than having your uh elbow close to you
and your hand out with the Palm pointed
towards the ceiling out to the side
you're going to switch around to your
elbow being pushed out away from you
with your palm pointed up towards the
ceiling once you get here continue
moving around until you find a spot
where you're starting to lose control of
the poy back up just a little bit gain
control get in 10 beats there and then
you can start to move forward to that
next spot where you're still working on
getting full control when you can wrap
all the way around yourself and then
exit you have completed this exercise
you want to do it with each hand so I'm
going to do the same thing with my left
hand and my goal here in going around
and getting it behind my back is to be
able to hold this steady for 10 solid
beats just like
that all right so step two of this
process is going to be that we're going
to learn how to get down Tic Tacs Tic
Tac are a POI technique that involve
passing the POI back and forth between
parallel planes on either side of your
body they're necessary for any kind of
3B weave and we need to learn how to do
them for our behind the back weave as
well here's how we're going to go about
doing that you want to start with the
pois spinning forward at your side and
you want to try and pass it around
behind your back and then back to its
original side behind your back and then
back to its original side you can go
ahead and just pass it back and forth
and hang out for a second and get your
bearings again pass it back and forth
hang out for a second and then get your
bearings again what you want to be able
to get to is be able to go straight back
and forth between these two positions
you want to get more and more
comfortable performing those behind the
back Tic Tacs let me show you what that
looks like from behind with my right
hand I'm going to pass it back and forth
basically keeping my hand in the small
of my back and I'm probably going to
want to move my upper body back and
forth just a little bit to help out with
this technique likewise we want to do
the same thing with our left hand we're
going to want to get it spinning
forwards on our side and we're going to
want to pass it back and forth behind
our back like so just to start off with
we pass it and bring it back hang out
for say like three beats we pass it back
hang out for three beats pass it back
now hang out for two beats pass pass it
back two beats pass it back and then
just switch back and forth between the
two sides again your goal here is to try
and see if you can keep this Tic Tac
going for 10 reps make sure you're not
hitting any of your body parts and if
necessary pivot the upper part of your
body back and forth in order to get
there and then you're ready for step
three step three we need to take those
Tic Tacs and turn them into TW beat
weaves whenever we perform any weaves at
all one of the basic steps we have to
get down is being able to have each of
our hands performing a Tic Tac in
staggered timing relative to each other
this is what gives us that lovely
wraparound feeling that happens every
time we perform a weave whenever we're
performing a 2B weave however there's
always one hand that leads and the other
hand that follows so in order to get to
a 3 beat weave we have to learn how to
let either hand lead through a TW beat
weave here's how we're going to do that
for this behind the back weave we're
going to go ahead and start off with the
Poise spinning forwards on our sides and
I'm going to pick a hand that's going to
lead in this case it's going to be my
right hand so when that happens I'm
going to bring my right hand around
behind my back and I'm going to let my
left hand go under it again I'm going to
let right hand go over left hand go
under right hand go over left hand go
under now I'm going to switch things up
and let my left hand go over and my
right hand go under like
so like so like so let me show you this
from the back here so the letting the
left hand on top like so and then
letting the right hand on top like so
left hand right
hand left hand and right hand so to get
this step down I would recommend getting
in a certain number of reps of a two
beat weave on each side and then working
your way down to being able to alternate
back and forth between the two here's
what that would look like we go ahead
and we start off with the pois spinning
forwards on either side of us and I'm
going to try and get in five reps with
my right hand going behind me thinking
one 2 3 4 and five then I'm going to get
in five reps with the left hand going on
top 1 2 3 three 4 5 then I'll try and
get in three reps with the right hand on
top one 2 3 and then three reps with the
left hand on top 1 2 3 and then we'll
try and go back and forth between them
thinking right hand on top and then left
hand on top and then right hand on top
and then left hand on top going back and
forth so the no BS is that that is
probably the hardest step of this
process but if you can get that down
you're going to be ready to put all of
these pieces together into that final
behind the back 3B
weave so for step four we're going to
start putting together the final pieces
in order to make the reverse behind the
back weave work here's how we need to
start working on the basic pattern of a
3B weave whenever we perform a two beat
weave we're always putting one hand
under and the other hand over but when
we perform a 3 beat weave we're working
in a set of instructions that are more
like under over back under over back for
a reverse 3B beat weave so we need to do
that behind the back here's what it'll
look like I'm going to stick my left
hand behind me and have it hang out in
the small of my back now I'm going to go
ahead and get my right hand pois
spinning forwards and I'm going to go
ahead and think that it's going to go
under over and then back
under over and then back once again
under over and back under over and back
if it's not clear what's really
happening here is I'm reaching my hand
for that first beat in between my left
hand and my back and then it is passing
from that cavity out around to being
further away from me than my left hand
so again we're thinking under over back
under over back under over back like so
you want to get this down with both
hands so left hand likewise is going to
go under over back under over back under
over back like so you want to get in 10
reps on each side and then it's time for
our final
steps okay so for step five we're going
to start putting things together and
we're going to play around with
something that's going to feel an awful
lot like that TW beat weave exercise
that we did for step three but we're
going to combine it together with the
pattern that we learned in step four
namely whenever we work with a reverse
3B weave I like to have my students
start off by just playing around with
swapping which hand is on bottom for a
moment so to think right on bottom left
on bottom open and then switch to left
on bottom right on bottom open just to
get a feel for what it's like to keep
that weave going continuously again
we think right on bottom left on bottom
open and then left on bottom right on
bottom open now let's do that with the
behind the back we shall we so I'm going
to go ahead and likewise think right on
bottom left on bottom open and then I'm
going to think left on bottom right on
bottom open again right on bottom left
on bottom open and then left on bottom
right on bottom open when you get a good
feel for this you can try and just keep
the weave going continuously right on
bottom left on bottom right on bottom
left on bottom right on bottom left on
bottom right on bottom left on bottom
here's what that looks like from the
side thinking right on bottom left on
bottom right on bottom left on bottom
right left right left and my friends if
you can do that and keep which hand is
on bottom swapping out continuously then
congratulations you have gotten down the
reverse behind the back three beat weave
good job so if you got down both the
reverse behind the back 3 beat weave as
well as the forwards behind the back 3
beat weave which if you don't have the
other one I'm going to go ahead and link
to my tutorial on it up in the cards as
well as down in the description you want
to have both because you can alternate
back and forth between them you can go
ahead and turn back and forth from the
forward to the reverse and back again or
hang out alternating between the two in
a behind the back waist strap and
doesn't that look cool and hey if you
like exercises for getting down
different po tricks and techniques then
I have got a tip for you and it's called
the flow Circle the flow circle is a
weekly exclusive lesson that's available
only to my patreon supporters each week
covers a new drill or exercise designed
to help you get down a PO technique
trick or Theory you'll be able to build
up incrementally and even better than
that support the channel while doing it
you can sign up over at
patreon.com direct Factor po if you
found this tutorial helpful I hope you
will consider leaving me a like a
comment sharing the video or subscribing
to the channel to help other people find
it and of course to help my channel
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I want to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much you
all rock and I could not have done this
without you if those of you out there
watching are not currently patreon
supporters but you like the work that I
do and you'd like to see me make more of
it the best way to do that is to do the
same thing that those flow patrons did
and sign up to support me on patreon
over at
patreon.com drexfactor po there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my to bring pois
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to check out
that other tutorial I did on the
forwards behind the back weave I will go
ahead and leave a link to that up here
on screen as well as down in the
description go check that out thank you
so much for watching make sure to get
out and flow yourself today and I'll see
you with a new video real soon take care
now peace